thank you very coming out my name is
Richard I work for a payments company
called stripe I do kind of security
things there you may have seen me from
such ridiculous things as a friend and I
hacked a skateboard and then made him
give us a CD for it so now we have the
only CD in the world for a skateboard
you can find me at these places on the
Internet
I kind of liked when I stopped by
disclaiming a little bit so I I've never
been to strange leap before in fact I've
never spoken in an event kid kind of
towards develop this before I've only
ever spoken about kind of security
research things and I didn't have a
whole bunch of an idea about like what
to expect from a strange loop or what to
expect or what I should like be trying
to get out of a talk and I really got
the feeling that like the bulk of
especially good strange link talks are
basically interpretive dance we'd like
some computers on the fringe which
unfortunately I'm not going to be able
to move up to today I'm honestly just
like not feeling super well and so I
kind of went through all of the bits
that I was gonna do card and like just
made a lot of screenshots so I can point
to them and like not be trying to do two
things at once which I'm hoping will
kind of like and with this going a
little bit better and so I'm gonna like
preemptively apologize for the lack of
like caught wheels and [ __ ] while I like
build computers which brings me to the
other note that I have in my notes which
is that I'm really Australian I swear a
lot and I'm sorry if that's gonna annoy
you I will try to keep it to a minimum
so anyway like why actually give this
talk like I think rust is pretty neat as
a security person who really likes
exploiting memory corruption bugs like
I'm vaguely concerned Brust is gonna put
me out of business but I feel kind of
confident that it won't compile those
were all so neat just because like
working at this like bizarre like
several layers of abstraction is just
like something I find really fascinating
the like the the satisfaction that you
get when like a huge number of moving
pieces all come together and you like
set PC to the start of your card and
like jump into it and like good things
happen is really exciting which is kind
of why I first got started tinkering
with compilers and when I started
fiddling with rust a couple years ago I
got really excited about some of its
properties and you know hopefully
there'll be some overlap between those
two things or this is gonna be a
he talked so how I guess like the most
obvious thing to do is like write a
compiler and his little code is humanly
possible and this is it so if you take
this and you compile it with a Russ
compiler the object emits will be a Russ
compiler and so I consider it just like
dropping the mic and leaving at that but
that would be kind of dull but like the
the machinations that make this possible
I actually think are like incredibly
interesting and the reason for this is
because Russ object model like the the
discrete packages in which it stores its
card contain all of the metadata
associated with them and so like for
example if you're compiling C card with
clang or GCC there is nothing apart from
the actual card for GCC or clang you can
like include into your code that would
just like give you a C compiler to play
with and your programs for runtime and
that gives you a tremendous amount of
flexibility in as far as like your code
can reach into the internals of rust and
then like fiddle with it and you can do
this really really transparently as long
as you don't mind kind of a fairly rusts
userland stability guarantees or quite a
thing rusts compiler internal stability
guarantees don't actually exist so
you're kind of gonna be stuck on a
version for a while and to do this you
need to include this feature gate which
means you have to be on a nightly anyway
and so one of the reasons that your
resulting object is so small is because
all of the rest compiler is just a
dynamic library that's distributed with
the compiler to you the end user and so
I had a like vague what even is a
compiler slide because I think it was
worth settings with Harn but basically
like the the dictionary defines it is a
computer program that translates
basically something that translates from
one thing into another thing which is
why I think the transpile improvement is
we add in querque like that thing is
also just called a compiler but like
this isn't super helpful especially but
like you know even once you have a grasp
on like where the compiler is you start
to think like well why do I want one for
the vast majority of things giggles are
curious
city I think is probably the correct
answer if you're actually settling down
to write a compiler I strongly suspect
that what you want is a compiler it
already exists and like to modify it but
there are some like really I'm actually
like incredibly interesting cases where
it totally is the right solution and my
friend my favorite one is varnish is
anyone here used varnish yeah cool a few
people it's like pH Ches like pet
project from years ago he calls it a web
application accelerator it's a proxy but
so it has this domain-specific language
called vcl which compiles to C card with
a bunch of like interesting guarantees
one of them being that everything that
vcl offers you runs in constant time
which does have to be a really important
constraint when you're like potentially
gonna shove like millions of requests a
second through this thing and so like in
spite of my disdain like they're totally
awkward here in times when you should
think like I'm a build a compiler I'm
gonna stick it in production I'm sorry
to answer the question on the last slide
like this is fundamentally what a
compiler is you like take some input you
pause it into some intermediate
representation you pass that through
something that knows how to generate
code probably assemble that into an
object and then you execute it great
except it's not really that simple it
winds up looking closer to this in the
real world which just has a couple of
extra steps so the basic notion here is
that like the red boxes are things that
you have and can look at and kind of
exist on the file system and the blue
boxes are properties of the compiler
they're they're pots of the computer
program that knows how to compile your
card and so realistically you take your
input you Lex it into an array of Terk
ins you pause those tokens into an AST
you purge n that into some assembly code
you assemble that into objects you link
a bunch of objects together you get an
executable to easy or not so I guess
like put made more concrete this is kind
of like what that pipeline winds up
looking like so this is like a really
trivial piece of C curd if you're paying
attention you will realize that this C
code can be optimized away to a single
jump instruction which would also be a
really really dull talk but so we wheel
X the input string into this like array
of tokens
the positive takes the rater khun's and
turns it into an abstract syntax tree
this isn't any particular representation
this was like a data structure I cooked
up while I was writing this talk
statistically there's probably something
that uses this exact format but I've no
idea what it is so then once you have
your ast you Drakkar gen on it and you
get native card or at least something
that you can translate literally into
native card this is where my grand plan
of like showing it visually started to
pull the pot a little bit so then you
turn it into assembly and like you it's
the same thing except I couldn't work
out how to make our tool use Intel
syntax so let's say TNT and then finally
you link it together into an executable
and I was like
I googled Mac o object hoping that
something really funny would come up and
I could use that as my last one but it
didn't so instead it's an executable and
then in the spirit of like talking about
how things work in the real world it
actually turns out that like this is
what your compiler looks like in that
once you have the ast like long before
you generate code from it you want to
like do some stuff right like in the
case of rust the borrowed checker is
gonna throw an error and make you hate
yourself and Brust but like in the more
general case like you might do some type
checking so you like verify that all the
places that you're calling functions
actually accept like there's arguments
you might do visibility checking where
you're checking that no one's perking
api's they're not supposed to be able to
prou that you might do you're kind of
like you're here checking which is
broadly what the like the word checker
and Russ comes down to you and then like
you almost certainly want to do some
optimization even before you get to code
generation and unfortunately like then
you realize that in order to like really
do cur here's testing you also need to
involve the linker and like this
pipeline doesn't make sense and
everything is talking to everything else
and it's that picture where it says like
why is Redis talking to MongoDB and like
oh god help sir
I originally was planning to kind of try
and like smash through all of this in 40
minutes and I realized that that was
untenable and also like just not gonna
be very interesting because I was gonna
wind up doing a lot of very very
aggressive hand waving in place of like
explaining things so instead what I
figured I'd do was I would implement a
really really naive and shitty compiler
in rust and then
I would aggressively hand-wave about all
the cool ways that we could use rust
machinery to make it better because when
I ran this talk I also didn't have time
for all of that so off the bat we're
gonna build a brain-fuck compiler
partially so I could justify swearing a
lot more in this talk and also because
brainfuck is neat and maps very very
well on to von Neumann machines so
basically if you've not seen brain about
brain-fuck before it has eight
instructions and so you can imagine the
the brain-fuck machine as being a
gigantic tape made up of cells with a
read head that sits on the tape and so
the instructions let you increment the
current cell decrement the current cell
move the cell pointer around it has a
loop construction which is how its
provably turing-complete in that when
you see the left bracket you jump to the
right one and less your zero sorry you
jump to the right one if your zero and
then two instructions for interacting
with the outside world because it turns
out not being able to do why you're kind
of sucks and so this is like they're
really small oh yeah I sort of feel bad
about bailing on the live coding but I'm
mostly kind of okay with it this was
like the naive interpreter that I
knocked out and so basically like I'm
gonna walk through this in a little
detail because I think it's probably
gonna become important later but like at
a really high level this basically just
takes a file reads a bunch of tokens out
of it
pushes them into this data structure
that we're calling program returns it
and so this is just kind of like rusty
setting things up I realized after I
made the screenshot that program is a
type alias it's just a vector of upcard
unfortunately I decided not to change my
slides to the last second we create this
macro for pushing which is one of the
things that's like honestly really
amazing when you start trying to tackle
a problem like this in rust is being
able to abstract your problems away with
like layers and layers and layers of
macro magic as long as you're the only
person who's gonna read or write this
card fabulous and so basically what this
does is if there is nothing currently in
the loop stack then just like push the
current instruction on to the current
program if you do have like an open loop
basically like there are some open left
braces then what we want to do is shove
this instruction into that left brace so
that we wind up with this like kind of
stack structure of program up codes of
which some are more loops and again this
is kind of made possible by rust having
like some types that let us be very very
expressive about the in like the intent
of the code which in this case is to
describe instructions that a virtual
machine critics acute by encoding it
into the type system and so the paws are
is really really simple because pausing
stuff where they're only single
character tokens and their own
context-free is really really
straightforward so basically we just go
through and like shove a bunch of stuff
into like basically shove all of the
instructions into this vector effectives
and then checking the loop stack is
empty is just like the one kirk here in
check that we get out of a brain-fuck
compiler which is deciding that we have
the same number of left and right
brackets and then we shove it back out
and so when you know that's great we
have this data structure full of
instructions but like it's kind of
useless if we can't execute them so I
built this thing key little interpreter
and it's really sort of it's pretty
straightforward there's like this like
unwrap um it's my favorite they they
took away the radio weight function
between me writing this code and this
talk but basically all this does is
iterate over the program in the case
where it finds a loop it recursively
evaluates the loop and then kind of like
does exactly what you think it evaluates
brain-fuck card gray but sir we're meant
to be talking about compilers
so let's generate some native code
instead so we can kind of like take the
operation of this card and turn it
directly into assembly really really
trivially this was my dumb
implementation which is just targeting
like an x86 machine and this is just
like byte for byte reimplementation of
exactly the same functionality when you
add you like increment of func when you
move you like shift the take point when
you add or subtract you add you perk at
the value pointed to by the take point
on Io is pretty straightforward as well
as long as you don't mind hog carding a
bunch of Sisko numbers yeah I it's not
even important if you like read native
code take my word for it this thing
rights of
like to send it out at the right the
value pointed to by ESI and then finally
for loops we like actually had to do
some real work right like up until now
there was basically like a single
instruction that did whatever it was
were interested in doing which was
pretty straightforward to occur gen so
what I did in the spirit of doing like
the the naive estanque
was I went through and I tagged every
single instruction with a label and then
at that label
I would then if I saw a jump I would
unconditionally jump to the other label
and at the other end I would check
whether another value is zero and if not
jump back and this was purely to protect
myself from a dumb off by one error that
I made a bunch of times that goes into
loop indefinitely but so basically we
can do some trivial optimization for
this right like a car generation time we
can go through and say like hey you have
160 ad instructions in a row why don't I
turn that into like the two upper in
form of AD that accepts like an argument
and turn it into like one instruction
instead of 160 which would be neat but
that would also be sort of like ignoring
this whole like rusty New Zealand thing
that I'm going for oh there's some
boilerplate associated with it as well
this again is like sort of not
interesting but I was very diligent and
like copy pasting all the stuff that I
was planning to talk about while I was
lifeguarding I mean if you're curious
basically there's a BSS section at the
southern object which instead of being
packed with data is an instruction to
the Lord as saying like hey reserve me
some space when you map this thing into
memory so we like create this gigantic
area they're called tape which is just
like 30,000 bytes
there's a dot function which knows how
to write a single byte and then our
start symbol basically says like hey
like Before we jump into the program and
like this works so this is what happens
if you run it I was on a hack trip with
some of my co-workers a couple of years
ago in La Jolla and somehow someone
noticed night Nell Hodge into writing a
queen in brain [ __ ]
for some reason which the whole time
I've been working on brain [ __ ]
compilers I've been using his the
default test case because it has like a
lot of less that nested loops like why
the hell not so like me
this works kind of it relies on like a
lot of ridiculous assumptions one of
them being that your language is
context-free and pretty straightforward
to pause another being that you're
running on x86 that the Cisco numbers
happen to be the same and additionally
it's extremely difficult to reason about
if you started like expanding the
instruction set of brain-fuck and saw
that involving like instructions that
take operands or more State or more than
one tape or Siskel's or basically
anything you would very very soon find
yourself really miserable because you
built this like unstructured message
spaghetti so like what if we wanted to
expand this into like a less shitty
compiler the the first obvious step
would be fixing code gen and I wanted to
like going a little bit of an adventure
to talk about like the current state of
compilers why and how they work the way
they do and like what we can learn from
that and so like GCC is architectural a
monolithic in that RMS went out of his
way to make it as humanly impossible as
humanly difficult as possible to
interact with its implementation because
he was concerned that someone would
build a proprietary back-end for it that
kind of sucks but even sir like in spite
of the fact that GCC skirt is very
tethered together
GCC still has a bunch of discrete steps
and it turns out that when you invert
GCC on the command line it's actually
just shelling out to a bunch of its sub
tools after like trying to infer what it
is that you really want it to do and so
like CC one is the compiler there is a
program called CPP which doesn't have
anything to do with C++ which instead
processes LD is the linker and so forth
and so then clang came along into the
scene in the last five years or so I
guess which clang is basically just a
GCC replacement there was a lot of
hubbub is like various logic projects
kind of on the order of an operating
system managed to migrate their way
across to using clang instead of GCC but
interestingly it has a very modular
architecture which is neat if you like
want to perk it the internals of a
compiler and it backs on to LVM and so
LVM is the low-level virtual machine
it obstructs the way your physical
machine in the way that before I was
writing out native instructions for x86
and so if you're like me and you're one
of the only people in the universe who
still cares about power P say for
example and you wanted to build this
card on PowerPC you would have to do one
of like a few things you can like
special case it and like use the config
flags and rustle like pulling the
PowerPC module that knows how to
structure it you can like do a bunch of
stuff but it's gonna be fairly miserable
so instead the approach that LLVM takes
is that you write this intermediate
representation which is basically
platform agnostic there I say basically
because unfortunately like
implementation details like always creep
in but like for the most part you can
write like pure card in IR and have it
like build for any target and then LLVM
both has a lot of infrastructure for
dealing with this internal
representation as well as sorry
intermediate representation as well as
free subsequently writing it out into
native objects that target the platform
that it is that like you care about them
and kind of is a furnace the example I
showed before and I forgot to mention
still hinged on a lot of an external
tools that the code that I showed off
was only capable of emitting the
assembly code kind of like as ASCII text
so you're still dependent on an
assembler and a linker and your various
other tools to turn it into native code
so like IR is neat because if we write
out i/o then like now we can have LVM do
like a bunch of grunt work forests it
also does things like optimize and
register eyes forests which is just like
busywork basically and sorry there was
in the side when I submitted this talk I
was like really acutely aware of the
fact that I was submitting a talk that
depends on implementation details of the
language that's like made it their
mission to change is humanly quickly pop
change as quickly as humanly possible
and sir like probably twelve weeks ago
they started to be like noises on on the
is a about like rust growing a new
intermediate format to replace kind of
like the internals of transit has right
now which are functional but kind of
annoying and so I was watching this and
it was like I might not get away with
this and it landed like a couple of days
ago I machine
of spite and so while it is awesome that
rust has this new intermediate format
and it would have been even awesomer if
I had had the time in the last couple of
weeks to learn how it works so I could
target that unfortunately I sort of just
didn't so they're still currently just
assumes that you're using rust one fall
I don't really think that's a problem
because if you copy/paste anything out
of this token and try to put in
production you've made a terrible
mistake anyway but you should probably
be aware that if like when I will push
all the card afterwards when you try to
build it you will need a snapshot of
rust one fall and this kind of speaks to
the the compatibility guarantees that
rust gives you in that like if it's
easily encoded like it's in Lib stable
they will go so far out of their way to
avoid breaking your card but they have a
fairly similar design contract to LLVM
internally which is that like the
internal should be good card it should
make sense it should be well documented
but if you feel like just actually sorry
that was one of the other things I meant
to mention earlier how many people here
have like written card that uses strings
in rust I'm sorry so I broke that once
it's like the biggest PL that I ever got
into rust which also Bert github was the
the renamed from Stratos string which
yeah the whole universe called fire
which I guess is kind of like the the
mechanism that they've now exposed to in
compiler Eternals which is that like you
can break pretty much whatever you want
you just have to fix all the coal sites
as well which I mean like I've taken as
though like try not to wreck yourself
principle but sort of like building
things now that we're kind of done with
our history lesson your earlier I pulled
the pot my like tiny rusty binary and so
what it was linked against and kind of
at least very strongly insinuated that
was probably some cool stuff in there
that we could use and like the most
obvious one is rusty LVM and so I'm
going to avoid doing the whole like
scroll through a mountain of code thing
because it's a little unclear to me that
it's actually helpful mr. Rosiello vm is
basically a high level wrapper or a
medium level wrapper on top of LVM and
so what it gives you is access to not
the whole LLVM api because it turns out
that there is a direct linear
relationship between like stuff of the
rest of
have wanted at some point and whether or
not it has bindings but like given the
maturity of the rest compiler at this
point that's kind of a lot of stuff and
using this we can do native code gen we
can have LVM involve the assembler
invoke the assembler and the link of
forests which will like save us a whole
bunch of time we can target other
machines very trivially the only thing
we have to come up to LVM is a target
triple and so it winds up looking a
little something like this so this is
just kind of like the top to give you
some idea of why I didn't want to scroll
through a bunch of boilerplate code
because there is a lot of it and at some
point I basically want to refactor this
talk into kind of like some Nate helpers
for TOI compilers on top of this but
basically you can go through and one for
one translate the calls that we're
making Mineta code that we're assembling
before into closing to LVM which you
basically get this builder interface and
then you call like like build F add for
example to say I want to add in two
numbers together and this gets hairy
pretty fast but it's like strictly less
hairy than like you're basically like
string templating your assembly together
so we'll take that as a win there is a
ton about LVM already on the web which
is also why I'm kind of tempted to talk
more about like rough specific things
I'm like how to drive LLVM but so you
basically have two choices at about this
point you can either drive LLVM directly
or you can try and drive rust and
tunnels directly and having tried the
second one and written a blog post about
it I'm like just not even going to
suggest you try it the unfortunate
reality is that the LVM bindings use
basically a series of opaque types which
rust doesn't use directly internally
like it's internal representation in
trans unfortunately doesn't use any of
them and so you have to pick your poison
upfront I'm pretty confident that just
using LOV em and like using the bindings
and building your own abstraction on top
of it is like almost certainly the path
to glory that said there is another
module called rusty driver and rusty
driver is exactly what it sounds like is
the moduli worked at the start to like
kind of stunt hack myself and cheat
compiler and so if you just open it like
if you're okay with the hideous compile
times of
rust over and over again and you just
want a dumb prototype like just going
shopping inside of rusty driver is like
the totally tenable option see but sir
all right we're gonna use LVM we get
free optimizer we get like an external
linkage story for free like all of a
sudden we can refer to external symbols
and like how good things happen we can
interrupt with other LLVM tools
archiving is sort of a solved problem it
turns out that archive is still
basically suck and we get like symbols
and like a debugging story Nate so like
what else can we fix about our dumb
compiler
well so I mean brain-fuck is sort of
dull right like at the end of the day if
we're writing brainfuck we're almost
entirely just writing machine
instructions for a really shitty small
limited CPU and so we can build out a
language that's a strict subset of rust
and turn it back into our existing kerja
machinery and in this way we can kind of
like incrementally build ourselves a new
platform on which to build code so like
this is basically the machinery that you
need to pause a rust file and Nick
Cameron gave a really fantastic talk at
a truss camp this year about like
building your own static analysis tools
but basically what this does is take the
code on the right and turn it into the
code on the Left which is a little
daunting and and so like given that
you're you're interested in like taking
your Eocene generating some native code
from it like it turns out the rest
patent matching capabilities are
basically the exact thing that you want
and so for example like this is the
chunk of card that in my like dumb
language that I implemented for this the
only thing that you're allowed to do is
define top level functions that has no
notion of Global's it has no notion of
shed skirt the only thing you can do is
to find functions with local variables
in them that accept arguments and so
we're basically saying like I want to
take every item in the crate which is
kind of the high level like level of the
level of abstraction in rust in that
translation unit is one great and I want
to iterate over the Nerds
the top-level module and every time I
get an item sorry an item is the high
level unit of abstraction for like a
thing
so like a config directive is an item a
global variable is an item a function is
an item every time I get an item that is
a function I want to unpack it post it
through a bunch of my analysis pauses
which indirectly do roughly the same
thing as far as they just Pat much like
a champ over it to try and extract the
local variables the statements the
arguments and the return-type and then I
shove that into my context and what I'm
left with is a context that I can hand
in to Kuragin to turn this into a native
object and so this is kind of what that
winds up looking like as far as like
extracting the statements and Wrightwood
drift is a very real problem that you're
gonna run into but sir
again it basically does exactly the same
thing at one point I was gonna make
declarations work and then I decided
that my language is cheaper and easier
without them so basically I'm taking the
set of semicolon terminated expressions
looking through and trying to find out
whether or not they're an assignment or
a call our function call which is the
only two operations that might be on me
that my language supports and then
handing it into more pauses and
conveniently this does mean you like if
you want to have locally defined
functions for example you kind of get
that for free like you can just like :
to yourself and so like rust density
here turns out to be really really
interesting purely because like the the
Wrightwood drift is hugely significant
you will spend a lot of time like
furiously unpacking objects but one of
the things that's fascinating about rust
is that it's error messages are so good
that like while you're on this like wild
mission to like patent match your way to
glory rust is actually extremely good
about saying like hey like have you
tried unpacking this other thing let me
tell you some more stuff about it which
makes the like compile fail to like work
in compiler iteration cycle really
really quick and so like this is kind of
what that winds up doing I like handing
in a file it inferred that I had a local
variable see it takes a couple of
argument
it has an expression which is adding the
bound variables a and B together and my
main function just like calls into my
fruit of Rs so I'm actually running
really ahead of time I'm also really not
feeling super well so I'm gonna wrap
this up le I'm afraid and I'm kind of
sorry but rust gives you a bunch of cool
toys to play with the sheer amount of
stuff that it gives you that you can
kind of like grab and pull apart and
fiddle with at compile time is really
significant and the the number of times
that I went down something that was it
became fairly evident that it wasn't
gonna work quite early on but it was
still like honestly kind of satisfying
to extend it all the way through the
failure was kind of like an interesting
and new experience for me having tried
this done in C++ before and rust error
messaging is fantastic as far as like it
turns out that with git grep and like I
used them so using the like make inside
of them and get crap with a single
buffer in the Brussels you can kind of
jump around I I think in many ways
quicker than if you're using eraser so I
didn't want to kind of try and node
snipe you into building some cool [ __ ]
because I want to play with it so one of
the things that's really bothered me
that kind of like inspired me to talk
about this in the first place
was why to compile is always target
native card so I used to maintain this
project called underscore VM that is
sort of it debacle it underscore be M is
itself a ruby DSL and basically what it
lets you do is I used to work on the IBM
project and I got frustrated by how
unmaintainable it was so I wrote a
rubbing DSL that emits Ruby code and so
I'm sorry that emits valid POSIX shell
code that like manages versions but it
does things like Constanta fication so
it doesn't leak any state into your
shell it's kind of exhausting but so
like reimplemented reemployment doing
something like that as like a native
language that backs on to plastic shell
it's something that I'm like really
surprised that no one has really
explored before I kind of assumed that
this would be a real thing
there's also definitely like Lib
syntaxes honestly kind of opaque and
it's unfortunate that if you
to use lib syntax as the pasa for your
toy language you are constrained to use
a subset of valid rust which can be
really frustrating you want it with like
a lot of type annotations that just kind
of like sit there for no obvious reason
so like better cooks into lib syntax so
that you can kind of like roll your own
pawza with less [ __ ] around would be
fantastic and one idea that I sort of
didn't explore but I think someone
should would be to abuse the rusty
plug-in infrastructure so like basically
when you wind up doing is at the top of
your program you you invoke like a
single macro and at that point you have
this like big hand wavy token tree thing
that isn't kind of like constrained to
be ballad rest yeah I updated my slides
before I go up on stage I can probably
answer like a couple of quick ones and
then I'm gonna go and run no I mean this
is good for me honestly but awesome
thank you so much for having me